per attenti ragazzi benvenuti avessimo
video sono parigi oggi siamo tornati su
naufraghi ed eravamo rimasti che avevano
trovato questo dungeon in mezzo al lago
in mezzo alla foresta in mezzo all'isola
in mezzo al sedere di pietro e la cosa
bella di questo dungeon qui che
dall'esterno sembra veramente figo però
noi sappiamo già che all'interno si
espanderà tale sempre come il sedere di
pietro quindi stai cos'è sta roba
sono blocchi di smeraldi come fai ad
averli con tutti gli smeraldi che
abbiamo ti sei fatto dei blocchi di
smeraldi ok ma non dovremmo scambiarli
con va bene e va beh va beh va beh
ragazzi allora quello che dobbiamo fare
entrare la dentro l'unica cosa che non
sappiamo che cosa ci troveremo quindi
pane a profusione che mi terrò tutto io
andiamo ai tutto non ho niente fermo
secondo non devo vestire sono nudo
allora abbiamo piccola abbiamo tutto
quello che ci serve in teoria potremmo
andare che dici che l'ex gara papa
parava para papa a parare questa la
sigari maria de filippi con dentro i
tronisti
sei pronto a c'è un boom allora prima le
signore no no no no no no no no no no è
troppo
no è una sfida è una sfida si sa chi
entra nel pozzo calcare se davvero la
goduria che voi non puoi cadere perché
ci si celebrerà questo casino e poi non
puoi cadere perché c'è lei della
d'andata di puro hard e buio geni che ci
sono amici per the amazon a scappare dai
lasciato il mio no no no aspetta allora
ricordati com'è andata all'altra puntata
ciao te lo ricordi com'era com'è andata
lo ricordo bene le cose non ci hanno
incornato tutti vai con le torce patrona
che brutto questo ti sei visto allo
specchio
allora notizia malvestito ok bravissimo
mai perfetto perfetto perfetto una
domanda ma è questo che deve porca vacca
di milano ma non me lo ricordo più
aspetta che stop che sto concentrata
dall'aspetto bene una bacca spacca nona
speriamo due cuori che spacca c'è una
cesta non ti dirò mai che cosa c'era
all'interno perché non per me ma smetti
arruolarmi vivo aiuta mi sento che ami
angolato prodotto deficiente l'asahi
stupido sono certo un po ovunque
nascono dai non prove così cattivo a
prenderti la roba da brin di madonna che
male che male che male che male da mino
ma roma è una cosa aspetta sulla sua
testata spiazzata sono troppi mobile non
posso far vendere un bene faceva niente
è meglio insomma scherzavo scherzavo
scritto menaye menaye ok ti ha salvato
quanto sei rimasto in nove cuori e mezzo
io ne ho due e mezzo a questo combatto
six slater dove vai dove vai qui sta il
vero avevo io ho io ho io meno che
sembra inseguire lima 6 minori che ha
reagito andando insomma entrando
incornando tutti a la spada me l'hai
data pensavo non volessi da avuto buono
sono sto contrasto voluto mi hai dato
anche pittorici di quelle che aveva dato
anche nella lane grande piero aspetta
tutta la roba contratto necessari cosa
tutta la roba che ho trovato necessaria
flores vagando non ti sento tutta la
roba che ho trovato aneliamo o la fibra
un gigabit sta allargando tua sorella di
aiuto
torna il re va bè cosa vedo allora ho
visto l'inferno
ecco bravo esatto 59
ciao ciao bello questo gioco impegnativo
ma maggiordomi qua sei scemo ma tu sei
tutto drogato ma perché è aperto
maledizione ma dai bastoncini fermiamo
tutto indietro dai 1 non è possibile
thousand years later
ora tu vai fuori e ci faccio io non sei
capace
no no lì che mi fai paura potete
ammazzare pietro per cortesia
no no no no tutti da pietro ammazza
ammazza ammazza ammazza
ma no dai ma perché ti sei scemo
spacchiamo intensi giorni cosa ok 1 la
gara 8 poi c'è un'arma tali gli
scheletri che neanche jack sparrow tanta
tanta tramite se devo farle rock e con
le di legno non hai capito il senso di
questa frase del legno nel senso si
cercasse di pietra era ancora meglio non
rimaneva combatte e china mobile bombe
da tirare perché quindi forza farti
vedere dai nemici per picchiare se ti
fai vedere di aia che male ok ok ok ok
buonarroti quanti nei lotti continuato
spacca 11 48 ma c'è ancora uno scheletro
ma quindi siamo praticamente aperta
spera vicino un altro rotto pure questo
ok ne manca solo uno che non riuscirò
mai a uccidere ok perfetto fatto o mio
dio
vuoi vedere che cosa sa che cosa è
dovuto tutto sto casino dami l'arco brut
coach corda
stai a vedere
allora facciamo così to hide armature la
spada alla gold e all arco byte sarei la
mia katniss everdeen e fatemi uscire di
qua no no no vedi che sei stupido nella
vita no basta o donna no no ho sbagliato
piove piove potrebbe andar peggio
potrebbe esserci pietro in questa serie
è invece che sfiga portai qui ti
proteggo tranquillo ma bravo mi
sorprende che tu riesca a fare qualcosa
di decente ma io che dormiamo amiche si
la pioggia guardando in faccia oggi è
passata mentre piove anche se ne stava a
guardare contenere bravo amiche cece
la pioggia non c'è non c'è più grande
dietro meteorologo poi andiamo via basta
hai un po il iv ratio nel deretano anche
solido ti do non sa come sono sulla
testa mal di pancia ma da materiali
poveri
il brodino questa sera è messa di si
sentì non rompere le palle per lutto e
se umano robot visita macchia o mal di
pancia posso avere mal di pancia è una
volta nella vita mi fa troppo mal di
pancia se cosa faccio devo fare per
forza passare mal di pancia che cosa
faccio per cagare guardo i video di
pietro ok ciao amico ci vediamo a una
maledizione cioè la barca non posso
statica è spaccata in qualche modo tipo
con l'idea non lo abbiamo detto no no no
scherzavo scritta no ai a ma avrai dei
ritardi ma tu hai dei problemi hai dei
problemi nel cervello madonna non hanno
micidio che mi sale questo lasci una
barca vai barca sei proprio fido
nell'anima
no no è rotto il cazzo ma guarda come
fare un calzino barca con una freccia
una scusa quanta roba è visto quando va
bene e poi la briglia da mettere al
proprio animale
vieni pietra one it later abbiamo guarda
c'è ci sono delle erbette sembrano una
vocazione satanica solo che manca il
sacrificato vieni qua e mezzo no grazie
sto bene così
c'è un cane li aspetta eccole grosso
delle ossa sentire da subito chiedo
subito non per noi ovviamente non come
picchiarlo non vi vediamo vediamo si
abbaia fermi fermi no no no questa è una
bella idea
ok così ti segue così sta fermo sei
sicuro di ha dei problemi questo cane un
po come te ok ora esce flash anche dopo
avere tre no se l'avete anch'io che
anche lei
pietro abbiamo un problema cosa che mi
seguono un po di cani ha detto cani che
mi bastò diventato un canile
guardalo ambientato nintendogs qui c'è
un villaggio in villaggio dove il
villaggio da gioco nel comparso in
questo momento buongiorno
abbiamo dei cani da vendere o cosa
volete in cambio di cani era santo di
quest'anno facendo vivere in condominio
o qui cavalli non ammazzarli cavalchiamo
ok va bene senti a parte il commerciale
ed aspetta che sta cavalcando un cavallo
fermo ad un difficilissimo eccolo mio è
riuscita come hai fatto tu
ma come ma sono io quei cavalli non
riesco a far niente allora facciamo così
i dati posto le cose per cavalcarlo ok
ciao amico
ciao amici bene
ciao amici sono il re che figata fa
vedere con una persona o un cavallo
quale lavora a cavallo che figata
non vale solo perché la lamborghini
calvo è chiaro questa mucca non sono io
che ero la mucca non ho la sella però
vabbè andiamo ai fatti strada tua almeno
cellula siliana qua c'è dell'ossidiana
su stato questo monte lo stai facendo a
morando dentro per non farlo scappare
per volte facciamo questa sera dando
anche aveva già fatto no no era kohler
anni quello che faceva vulcano ha mai un
dungeon e book di ci credo
ci sono delle nuvole dentro lucano ci
sono gli zombie anche questi sono erano
due amanti che provavano a fare le cose
loro ma siamo arrivati noi a romperle
bolla o mio dio subito scusa scusa scusa
mi dispiace volevo togliere l'altra
torcia altro giuro che non l'ho fatto
volevo farlo hanno fatto ha passato oggi
ci provo mamma mia che è una creazione
fatto mamma mia carriera il più supporto
da lontano dove sei finita la negazione
cazione guardali guardali speck e spacco
tutto c'è una cesta giga 10 smeraldi un
cesp leight che mi serve perché sono
nudo gli manca solo quello ma a posto
porca vacca
ok occhi e ci sono ancora degli cosi li
davanti e raucci dove l'acqua è rimasto
fuori cava h cosa ho visto cosa ha
trovato nella vita crociera mente guarda
che roba ho trovato codices plate
il pool sette o otto quadri adami con
l'inferno almeno io la god is war the
gods libus godley leggings lynch speight
cordialmente pensa un po che dici
comunque morire come a rischio la
cameriera esatto impossibile ci siamo
pietro stiamo per uscire 6 no ma sono
zombie aiuta stavo per vedere la scena
primo bella della vita
stai per morire emozioni e invece troppo
forte ma trova bene occhio uscire che ci
sono un po di zombie va dai ragazzi io
direi che lanciando gli zombie poi giù
dalla montagna
se riesco altrettanto pare c'è un
problema dimmi che c'è molta al cavallo
doppia fila il cavallo in doppia fila
io direi che possiamo andar via da qua
ciao pietro non è nono spararmi non vale
non vale no no no ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto che ci vediamo in un
prossimo nel prossimo video in teoria
dovremmo riuscire a finire tutto perché
dovrebbero mancare forse 12 d'angelo ei
pochissimi ei e vi sia piaciuto come se
mi piace anche la descrizione solo se
rischiate vie avanti tutta beh ragazzi